Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Outlast.
I don't know who's banging back there, but can you calm it down until I get into this episode?
So we just came down into this cave, and I believe...I'm not a hundred percent sure
But I belieeeve- ohhh no
Ohhh~
Oh --is that -- oh
[rocks rumbling]
Oh, Larry. You know you shouldn't have tried to escape.
I'm just wondering how you died down here...
Oh, how did you did YOU die down here?
[nervous laughter]
How did all of you die down here?
It looks like you got...crushed.
I guess it doesn't bode well for me but
IIIIIIIII shouldn't have said dick diddly squat.
[nervous laugh]
Ok, alrighty, that's how you're gonna play.
Well I believe in myself, as the protagonist of this story I think I'm gonna be okay.
Unless I'm not the protagonist.
And I thought about this. I did, in between the last episode and this one
I thought about this
what if Blake here...
And I know everything's crumbling and falling around me,
but I'm gonna take a moment about this one
what if Blake here isn't the hero that we all think he may be.
Because there's a lot of emotions that would cause
people to remember the past like that, or have it be haunting them
and one of the emotions is guilt.
And there seems to be a lot of play on sin
[Mark groans at sudden creepy singing]
[scared Markiplier noises]
[muffled shrieking]
Okay...
There seems to be a lot of people screaming down here.
But if they could stop screeamwamming and then I'd be much better.
But what if Blake isn't so innocent in Jessica's death...
[creepy singing continues]
Oh it's definitely in front of me.
Ugh
Hello!
[singing trails off abruptly]
Okay, you just drift off into the distance here.
Alrighty- oh good, lets definitely.
Oh, a lovers' embrace. Oh good. Oh that's nice [nervous laugh]
Delightful. Seems like these people down here just live the most fun-filled life you could possibly imagine.
But again. Like I was saying, what- [sound of disgust]
Alrighty then, they're down here.
But what if Blake somehow was complicit- Ugh. Hello!
You're gonna get squooshed. You're gonna get squoashed.
Alright, you stay over there and die horribly.
I'm gonna press on and squiz through here
I don't know, it's just a theory at this point, a game theory, but it-it-it, it would make sense
in terms of why that first phone call said something about kissing or
[scared Markiplier noises] Wh-hey, hi!
What am I supposed to do, am I supposed to run here I can't see anything.  Hello?
Oh hi. Oh hi. Hello. Good to see you. Oh, I'm sure we are.
I don't know what, I'm not that hungry. This is my only face.
Is this a better face?
[the most fabulous Mark face]
Mother burn. Mother burn? Mother burn?
Mother burn. Ok.
I don't understand.
Okay, congratulations.
Okay good...
Alright, you want to see it?
[BEAUTIFUL Mark face]
Oh god no [nervous laugh] Oh boy, oh nice face there, that's a good face.
Uh oh
Squoosh, oh, squaush
Oh you guys, oh that's what you get.
Oh am I about to be- Where'd you go?
where'd you go where'd you go
where'd [yells]
Oh God you didn't go anywhere
Fuck- where, where am I?
Where was I?!
God damn it, we-I mean-we we we [spluttering]
Alright, that was totally my fault there [laughing]
that was 100% my fault.
I'm just gonna start going and you can be back there and, uh, die preferably
because apparently this whole place is going under
and everything is going wrong.
Okay I gotta sprint out of the...the tunnels of the naked people
alrighty then
Hey what is everyone's- okay, thank you very much for that.
Just gonna squiz along here
Don't rub your true face on me
I'm good with my jovial fake face, if you know what i mean
Alrighty, then [winces]
Fruit of my lust!?
Are you sure it's MY child?
Oh... I don't know if I wanna watch...
I don't know if I wanna watch at all...
Ooh that looks bad
I probably shouldn't go under there.
I don't know, I gotta find it and I gotta break it
Yeah I gotta follow these wires I guess while also avoiding death on wheels
Hello, hi okay
W...walker?
Uh oh! HEY! I DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT!
Mooo-aaah [scared Mark noises]
I didn't do nothing! I didn't do nothing!
Uh oh
Oh hi...okay you're still there and you're still naked, good.
I didn't mean to go this way, there was another way that I was trying to go
and I didn't mean to go this way, I didn't mean to go this way, I didn't mean to go this way
I'm going backwards now God damn it
Alright fine, you wanna play with me?
Huh? You wanna play? Huh?! Ring around the rosy baby!
mmmuuhh [crying baby impersonation]
Alright fine then
Looks like you're just as slow as me in this water, so I guess it doesn't matter to you.
Okay so I just gotta follow the wires and find my way back
and then I should be able to get through there without dying a horrible zappy death
Oh here we go
I think I'm finding something
God damn it, could I stop running out of breath every few inches
Jeez get some exercise
Okay wait, no not that
That's not what I meant to- oh that's good. Off...that's a always a good thing
Can I...can I climb under there?
I don't know where I am but
Where am I?
Oh I don't know where- I think I made it to the other side
I-I-I-I think
I don't know where she is
I hope you don't mind the fact that I'm still wearing clothes
I just prefer it that way. It's awfully cold down in these drafty mines
I turned that off! I turned that off!
Oh shit, I 100% turned that off!
Oh no, which way you going?
Ooh eee...you don't see nothing
Whoa...but I turned that off!
Is there more than one? There's gotta be more than one then.
Oh, each of these split off on a divergent path.
Okay.
So where do you go?
Oh you crisscross under there, okay.
So if I can just...
I can't see shit, but here we go!
[gurgling noises]
I think I did that?
Oh, right here...okay!
Alright, got it!
So I just need to find one more
I think it was just three of them and then it's good.
Oh I didn't even need to crawl under there!
That was just me being a big dumb idiot!
Okay.  So there's one more, where does that go?
Where does it go, baby, where does it go...
Where does it go, over there, okay okay...
Come on, skedaddle man...
[wailing starts]
Oh I thought that was gonna be a thing.
Alright.
So you're just going there
Can I break that or something?
But that just goes to there, that doesn't go anywhere...
Was that the only one, why are there only two then?
Aw, I think that was it.  Okay.  That was it.
Here we go.  Good.  Okay...
Nice trap, why did they DO that?
Why do they have power down here anyway?
Ha-BLUH-ski!
Whoa, okay.
Don't ask me how that worked physically, because I don't know
Alright, where are we where are we?
Oh wowie zowie
Looks like I'm gonna have to do something 'bout this.
Booosh it
[groaning noise of maximum effort]
Alright.
Goodbye, then.
Where you going?
[long frustrated groan of realization]
Ohh no!  Wait, are you coming back?
Okay.
Alright, you're coming back
Ah, rollie pollie
And then I switch swotch it
sha-boop!
"Can't keep a secret from yourself."
See, that's what I was thinking!
[excited] shaa...
...aw.
Not enough force on that bad boy.
Alright I get it, I need to push it up and then get a
lot more "oomph" behind it.
Then I can smash into this thing.
Oh what, I can't pull that all- I gotta pull it all the way back?
Alright...
[raises voice] Hope no one's behind me!
Lady, if you're there
and still naked, just play some strings!
Join the band back there!
They'd love your company.
[disgusted noise]
With your "true face" and all that...
If there's one thing an orchestra respects, it's a true face.
A'ight, go for it!
Go, go, goooo!
Blap!
Okay. Cool.
Hey!  Oh hi!
Why were you there?!
[creepy screeching music]
That didn't make any sense.
You still there?
[creepy music continues]
You still there?  No. [music stops]
Where the hell would you go?
Where the hell did you go?
Why were you there, in the first place?
That didn't make any Goddamn sense at all.
Oh well...
Continuing on.
[muttering] Wherever the hell I'm supposed to go...
Hey, is that just the water area again?
Oh, I goofed it.
I goofed it real good!
Okay.
Well here we go.
Need batteries soon enough, I don't think I have nearly enough...
I've got two.
[mocking tone] Oh, "nothing matters but Lynn!"
Okay, they went down there
There's nothing over here so I gotta go down too.
Let's see if I can figure- oh!
NOW I go down a ladder!
Oh, NOW it works!
Okay.
[creepy breathing]
Hi!
[Blake screams] Hello!
Wha- okay!
What happened?
Did you scream for nothin', man?
[scared Mark noise]
Okay...
Lots of dead bodies everywhere.
BOOFT!
Got it.
I'm currently at level "Booft"
[Val being creepy]
I don't know if you love me at all!
Oh hi!  Okay!
You love me VERY much, apparently!
[very scared Markibaby noises]
[Mark decides to cheer himself up by singing]
Are you behind me?
Oh you are, arent you?
Oh, you're crawlin' behind me!
[frustrated] Could- could could- could, could, could ya...
Could ya JUST-
Oh, hey whoa oh God, you're very close
You're very close to me and I don't like it!
Oh, I don't like that none!
OH I don't like this none, at all!
AT ALL!
This is not good.
Habadabooski!
Habada-booski!
Oh-ho no thank you!  No no no no!
Oh God, this claustrophobic bullshit!
Alright, I see how it is...
Here we go here we go here we-
Oh, still crawling!
Oh, that would've been death, oh good!
Hoobidy hoopty!
[panicked groans]
Ah, oh.  Oh!  She went the other way!
[panicked Mark noises]
Habada-booski~
Ooh, very very narrow
I can't see anything...
uh- [SCREAM OF MORTAL TERROR]
Fuck.
Alright, well that do- oh!
Where are you?
Okay. Go that way, I guess
[menacing splash]
HEY!
That was a splish-splash behind me!
I wonder whose-
Wait, was that me, or was that her?
Oh...guess it's just me.
Oh, hi.  Where are you?
Where are you?
Hi?  Hello?
Hello, is that the glory?
Oh, okay...
Don't know if she's still-
Oh, I thought I saw her.
Okay.  Don't know where I'm going.
Well, that leads to nowhere.
[Blake starts groaning]
You still here in the water?
Wait, was there something over there?
[groaning continues]
Ugh.
Apparently I'm not doing okay.
Thought I saw something.  Nah, nothing!
Waste of time.
[creepy ambient music]
Oh boy.
I think I still hear her in the darkness!
And that ain't good, if you could leave me the fudge alone!
That'd be nice.
If anyone could leave me the fudge alone for just a few seconds, that'd be great.
[whooshing noise]
Why am I here!
[silence]
The fuck was that?
Hello?  Oh, hi!
Oh hi.  Hello, what are you doing there?
Don't mind me...don't mind me.
[whooshing noise] OH!  Whoa.
[chase music starts]
Got fucking whiplash right in my eardrums...
Why were you over there?
What am I supposed to do?
Where am I supposed to go?
How am I supposed to be able to get around you?
Ohhh no, oh no!
Oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
Oh no, oh no! No no no no no no no no
No no no no no no no no! No!
The opposite of that!
No no no no no no...
Okay, all right.  Is that a battery?
Can I have that?
Okay, go go go go go go go-
Oh, this is a dead end!
Oh God oh God oh God!
It's a Goddamn dead end!
[high-pitched scream]
Fucking ow!
Owie!
Frick-a-dick!
Is it over there, is that where I'm supposed to go?
I can't see!
[panicked noises] Uh no it's not!
Ohh no, I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead!
Oh it's all a red herring it all means nothing, it's nothing!
Oh wait, no!  It WAS up here!
Well that was so hard to see!
Ugh, that's the story of this game, huh?
"It was so hard to see!"
Yes indeedy doo it was
Hi.  I thought you were...
I thought you were, uh...what's-her-face, Val.
Or whatever it is.
[chase music stops]
I don't know, is Val gonna be at the top of this?
Well I'm not healed, but hopefully no one hurts me up there.
No, they would never hurt me.
They LOVE me!
Oh yeah...[fake laughter]
Okay, let's heal up.  Ugh.
Yeah I wonder how many times I've bandaged this one wound.
How infected could one wound possibly be...
The answer is excessively...
And with many contaminants.
Such as the leprosy, and the Iran.
Like such as...
[creepy sound]
Someone was up there.
I don't know if that's important for me
but someone was up there.
Okay.
Hey, who built this place?
And why did they phone it in so hard?
Ugh...
Alright
Nice and easy...
Nice and easy.
Nice and easy!
Okay.
Nice and easy.
Not that way, apparently.
Am I supposed to jump somewhere, or is this just a skedaddly-doo...
End of the road.
Oh, I'm supposed to jump up maybe?
Yeah.
Alright.
[loud sigh] Oh boy.  Okay.
Does this seem familiar?
Which way am I supposed to go?
Oh, not that way apparently because I don't think I can go that way.
Shoobadeeboo-ska, hope this doesn't drop again!
Okay, there we go.
Reloading! Ugh.
This has been one wild ride.
Hello.
Oh, a piece of paper!
Ah, chapter fifteen:
[dramatic voice] "And God spoke from the mouth of Ezekiel so that his ears bled,
and his teeth cracked, and the seed issued from his inspired loins,
and in his words were the blood of Christ."
"And of this blood was a river,
and its sustenance healed the festering wood of the trees that bore the seven nations."
"By the blood of the...spider-eyed lamb shall fall forever."
"And they that remain shall need no light,
neither candle nor electric flame, for vision shall be an eternal dawn."
"Seal not the prophecies of my word,
but copy them even exact of letter and with every waking moment of thy life,
for I am thy fellowservant, and of thy brethren the Prophet, and father,
and as shepherd say only this: God will reward you."
"Be ye filthy, be ye just, be ye unjust, be ye clothed in shame or in glory,
in time God shall [laughter] f-fuck ye with it...and so shall be thy reward."
"We all of us are Alpha and Omega, and Ezekiel the first among all,
and ye shall climb the tree of life or be crucified upon it."
"Only the chosen of God shall find sanctuary within Temple Gate, for without there are whores, and killers,
and idolaters, Pharisees, 'publicans, blasphemers, tax collectors, and tyrants."
"And the angels say: God turned away from man until the time his son Jesus Christ came to testify unto you."
"Jesus Christ turned away from man until the time his Prophet Sullivan Knoth came to testify unto you."
"And every word of the Prophet is true for it is written in this book, and this book is the truth."
"You shall testify these things, and in you shall be...[hesitates at creepy noise]  the book of life,
and you shall live in this holy city, and you shall say come quickly, revelations, even in my suffering,
even in the death of my children, come Lord God and give me paradise."
"The grace of God and his prophet Sullivan Knoth be with you all.  Amen."
Oh man, this Sullivan Knoth sure is high-and-mighty of himself!
And uh, of course it's the truth
because Papa Knoth said it's the truth
and you all wrote it down word for word, how truthy it was
and therefore the truthy is the truth~
Circular logic be damned.
Oh excuse me while I s- [winces]
Hello?
I see you in there!
What are you doin'?
Dancing?
Oh, I love a good dance!
Oh can I join ye?
Nice butt. [Mark plz]
So uh...oh.
Hi.  What are you doing?
Ew.  Don't...don't do that.
Ugh, don't thrust your hips
ya freakin' weirdo, with your "true face."
[nervous yell]
Ska-doosh
Hey, hi.
[yells dramatically] My eyes, your pocket sand got me!
Alrighty then.
[stoner voice] H-hey!  That's mine!
Hey, stop it!
Hey! Oh, you-you, y-you're jerks
All of you. All of yeee...
[creepy whispering]
I don't know what I did,  what are you talking about?
Uh oh.
Uh oh.  Is that Lynn up there?  Please tell me that's not Lynn.
Oh boy.
[creepy whispering continues]
I don't wanna watch!
Oh, what am I watching?
Ohh boy...
Oh boy.
Uh...
Uhh!
Ow!
[Mark's "I am so done" face]
I don't want any!
Ugh, I don't want any!
Oh hi, okay.
Hello.
[music fades]
Okay...
Mark's "The hell just happened" face]
[creepy grinding noise starts in background]
[seriously, that face]
[creepy grinding noise gets louder]
[noise drowned out by eerie music]
Okay...?
Uh....
Weird?
Alrighty then.
[grinding and music continue]
Ugh.
Are you Jessica, or are you Lynn?
I can't remember if a name was said in this...endeavor.
Hey, I wanna go.
Oh [nervous chuckle] I thought we weren't going this way,
I thought, I thought we were going through that door over there.
Alright.
Where are we going?
And why?
About what?
Oh, you're Jessica.
Oh, I see.
Uh-huh...
Okay.
Okay, thank you.  I think.
Also why are we here...
at what amounts to be 9 o' clock at night?!
Why are we here?
Why are we here, Jessica?
What the hell is happening?
Every time I've been here before- I've been here, revisiting my memories
but I'm literally reliving the exact memories
and why?
No idea.
[mumbles]
Well,I think- ooh boy...
[mocking] "For journal!"
Why- what class?
Ugh.
No!
Ugh...
[grinding and music get louder]
[sudden realization]
[disgusted groan]
[more disgusted noises]
NO!
[unhappy Mark noises]
uh, but is...[stuttering]
[grinding and music stop]
[mocking] "Responsibility."
What the hell kind of bullshit is this?!
Ugh, someone dial 911!
Ugh...
Oh boy.
Maybe that's where the guilt cims- comes from.
Oh Jeez.
Oh boy.
That's probably where the guilt's from!
[Jessica screams]
[screams continue]
Going right- [interrupted by screaming]
I'm on the way!
Oh boy.
I'm on the way, as fast as I can!
Ugh.
Ugh...oh boy.
[suspenseful music]
[sound of child sobbing]
Oh!
Uh...
Huh, what?
[chase music starts]
What- no, no, where? Where?!
No!
What the hell?
What the hell?!
What the hell!
[rocks rumbling]
So she never actually hung herself.
What?
Oh my God!
Ugh.
Uh...this is messed up.
Like, just ALL of this is messed up.
Man.
So...
[Blake yells]
Okay!
Hey, and I'm just trying to wrap my head around this and I gotta run away from that?
Ugh.
Alright, here we go again I guess
[faint wailing noise]
Oh my God.
What?
Lynn!
[lightning strike]
Oh my God!
What the hell?
[groan]
uh...
Yeah, I'll record this!  Don't worry, I know this is a very
pressing moment, but...
Gonna...gonna get this for posterity's sake.
I guess we're gonna follow the fiery moon.
Or something like that.
Oh, what is happening here?
Oh, well can't go that way I guess.
Ugh.
Where- where are we going?
I don't even know anymore!
Jeezums.
It just seems like this place just brings up...
all of your darkest memories.
I don't know.
I don't even know if it's connect-
[screeching noise] Oh...
Wait.  Can I take a second here?
Wait, where'd Lynn go?  Alright, well...
Lynn- Hang on, Lynn!  I just need to see this.
Whaaaat!
Ah, mmm I don't think that's...
That- that ain't right, okay.
Well hey Lynn, how's it going there?
I mean Jessica, I...I guess.
Jeez.
Blake has lost his damn mind.
He's just so caught up- he even said "find an adult."
Like, what in the world is that even about.
Is that the sun?!
[more lightning]
And what does he mean by snow? This clearly isn't snow!
This is...this is the apocalypse!
Okay, alright.
Alright I don't know where we're going but I think we're going the right way
following the sun.
Jeez, where are the four horsemen?
Where's Papa Knoth?!
Ugh.
Jeezums.
'Cause I just don't get- I don't get it.
Like, obviously the past is haunting him, but...
And obviously Priest Laudermilch is a disgusting horrible human being but...
just, my God.
Oh I can't go that way.
That's all locked off, so there's gotta be another way to get around here.
Come on, Lynn!
Jessica, whatever your name is, let's skedaddle.
We gotta...get going here, or else we're gonna die in the storm.
Jeezums.
Oh good, yeah this is good.
Just shove yourself right in that hole.
Okay.
Great.
Oh yeah.
"I'm sorry!" Yeah the one thing I wasn't supposed to do, I did that.
And now...[laughing] you mean your coccyx is broken too?
So's mine!
Oh, this bed looks good.
Oh boy.
Is it all right if I record this?
[hellish screeching]
Oh hi!
Oh!  How are you?
Why are you here?
[sobbing] Why are you here?!
[chase music starts]
Oh Jeez, don't tell me I gotta run away from her while we're doing this.
Oh Jeez...
Yeah, it's not- it's not good is it?
Oh okay, alright then.
Yeah, no joke.  You...you got pregnant in a matter of hours.
That's probably bad.
Too bad, we gotta keep going.
Apparently.
Or else we're gonna die.
'Cause I'm pretty sure she's devout enough that she doesn't want this baby to be born...
so we're just gonna have to skedaddle a little bit longer here.
How 'bout you go there?
No?
Not that bed? Oh not comfy enough for you I see!
Fine.
Oh, that's not good.  Okay!
Hi.
Uh, okay.  No!
God, no!
NO!
Uh, no?
No.
What is this?
No...
Oh boy.
Ooooh!
[gleeful] Oooooooh!
Sweet divine intervention!
Well, that's something to...declare.
To the heavens.
Alrighty then, off we go. [starts singing]
[continues singing]
Do we go back, or what do we do here?
Nah!  Is that bed good enough, baby?
No?
Oh, you're so picky.
[laughing] You're so picky when you're about to birth the Antichrist.
Oh, Jeez.
Another one of your cravings again?
Human blood?  Oh gosh.
I just went and got you human blood last night.
Ugh.
Oh boy.
Keep following the fiery sun, I guess.
Man, this is- this is all an illusion.
Like, it's gotta be.
Yeah.  Kind of just like that, huh?
Kinda like that!
I'm...I'm just willing to put money
that this is all in our minds.
Like, this is some orchestrated thing
that's playing out, because of some psychological influence from some...
that- that device that they were talking about.
They're seeing the signs of the apocalypse
and it doesn't necessarily mean that it's all true.
I mean, is she...
There's no way that it's actually the Antichrist.
There's no way.
I...I can't believe that.
Like it just can't...[lightning strike] ...ugh.
I don't know.
Oh.
[laughter] Is it the baby?
'Cause that's...
Oh, I wonder!
You know, I just thought I'd ask!
Y'know, you never know what it could be.
Could be a lilttle bit of, you know, pain in your lower lumbar?
[garbled mocking]
[more mocking]
Oh.
Alright.  What am I- what am i documenting here?
That's...that's a nice cart.
Oh, here! [laughs] Oh, this!
[screaming] Oh God!
Oh.  You gonna mind if I just...you gonna mind if I
review this foota- whoa.
Did that just fly up into the sky?
Huh.
Yeah, the "impossible child."
Yeah.  No, okay.
Yeah alright.
Okay.
What about this thing?
No, no.  Too small.
Uh hello.  How are you doing?
Not so good?  Yeah, me neither apparently.
I mean [laughs] I'm complaining...
ugh, "it's cold?"
We're almost there, I think!
[dramatic music and lightning continue]
Uh I don't think he's gonna help us now...
Alrighty then.
The heck...oh up here, okay.
I'm gonna make my way to the chapel apparently.
Because the best place to birth the Antichrist
is a church!
Yeah okay,
Since that other bed wasn't good enough for you.
Alright, we're in here now.
Papa Knoth, are you gonna pay us a visit?
[music and lightning stop]
Okay...oh!
Ugh.
Yes, the stretching rack.
[sarcastic] Great.
Perfect place, nice angle!
[chuckles]  "Lie DOWN!"
Ugh...
Oh boy oh boy oh boy...
Oh boy.
[Mark's "do not want" face]
[baby wailing]
[thunder resumes]
[Blake sobbing]
[sobbing and baby noises continue]
[Blake yells]
[baby noises continue]
[crying baby fades]
[creepy music starts]
[music continues]
[creepy music escalates]
[gurgling]
[music fades]
[laughs] Blake's just like
"Okay, gonna step away from this situation."
Oh my God.
My whole- this whole episode, my face has just been...
[Mark face]
...this whole time.
I can't [laugh]
this...what is this [sobbing laugh]
This even.
[sigh] Madness!
And what the hell...
[sobbing laughter continues] what the hell is all of this...
What the hell is the- can i go in the confessional?
Can I just talk about this?
My God!  No, I can't even do that.
Oh yeah [laugh] Let's record this for posterity.
You know, a few last blips and blaps.
Maybe I should've had the camera up for good ol' Papa Knoth, but...
Oh, man.
Oh what a beautiful day! [laughter]
[choir starts singing]
Oh!
Oooooh!
Loverly!
[sigh] So everyone's dead, huh?
I imagine that everyone's dead
Everyone in this town died
And no one's left alive, even Papa Knoth is dead.
It's just me and this baby.
And look at that big bright beautiful sun. [laughter]
It's gorgeous!
Burn me up, burn me, just burn me alive.
Burn me good.
Hello...
Oh man.
I still- I still can't believe this!
I st- I still can't!
What is that?
[ground rumbling]
Oh no...
Did they all kill themselves?
Is that what happened here?
They all killed themselves?
Who...who you talking to?
Talking to yourself there?
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, huh? Cyanide.  Okay, alright, yeah.
Well...
[disgusted groan]
Jeezums.
Jeez!
So everyone is dead.  Everyone is dead.
Everyone.  Everyone's dead.
OH NO!
Welp, goodbye!
And it was all...oh.
[choir continues]
Okay, what's back here?
Huh?
Trying to hide something from me?
Trying to hide something from me..?
Huh?
Trying to hide something from me?
Oh, I see you trying to hide something from me!
Huh?
Hello?
What's going on?
Huh?
What's going on in here?
Alright FINE.  You're not trying to hide something.
But I'm on to you.
Oh, I'm on to you...
Hello!
Okay!
Where's "over here?"
Uh, I'm on the way!
Okay...
Ah okay, this is just all part of the same memory.
Oh, thank you, that's...
Th...that's not very comforting, you know?
[choir chanting increases]
[choir stops but voice continues]
[credits music fades in]
Oh!
Aaah!
[screams of frustration]
NO!
[laughing] That can't be the end!
No!
Explain!
EXPLAIN!
No!
No...
[laughing sobs]
So, it really was...
The Antichrist!
And everyone's dead, and the whole world is ending, and everything has gone to literal hell.
What the hell [laughing]
I was banking on the possibility that it was all not real!
But...it...there HAD to have been something about it!
There had to have been, there was something about it!
There was...I d- I refuse
to believe that the ACTUAL Antichrist
came in there and just noogied everyone into submission.
Huh?!
There's no way!
Uh-uh, uh-uh.
There's something about that noise and that light...
that was a psychological signal.
There was some technology...technology and experimentation happening.
I refuse- REFUSE -to believe that was it.
There is no way.
Ordinarily, I'd...I'd give credence to things like this
and say "maybe you should take things at face value" but no!
There were pieces of the puzzle that were there.
There were pieces of the puzzle that were there
and maybe if you dug deep enough you would have found the truth.
And the truth can only be that there was some other influence.
Across the lake...
There was the power plant!
Those trees with the "fake leaves" that that note said.
Maybe there were more notes like that
and that's the ONLY one that I found.
But it was something even that guy said in the note
that as he got closer the...the visions got more powerful!
And as I was moving towards it
and...and the heretics in those caves were probably
right on top of the play as far as that goes
and so they had everything distorted in their mind
and for some reason this psychological thing
brings up old memories.
And maybe it's a factor that they're all so devout anyway.
They were devout anyway.
So their beliefs were amplified so hard, and their guilt and their shame
and their, quote-unquote, "sin" was amplified to an extreme degree.
Like, they were already a cult!
Like, they were already a cult.  Let's give them that.
They were already in this belief system when they got there.
Things started coming to reality because
of the experimentation that must have been happening to them.
That...HAS to be it!
There is no other explanation.
Why didn't you explain anything?!
The sun didn't blow up and kill everybody!
I'm willing to bet that!
There's no way!
[angry Markiplier noises]
No way...
You better tell me something at the end of these credits.
You'd better tell me something at the [frustrated whispering]
[angry Mark growl]
[awkward silence]
Aah, I'm just gonna...[frustrated muttering]
There has to have been something, there HAS to have been
something, because I missed...many a thing.
It doesn't show me all the things that I've missed, here.
But...
it does show a lot that I've gotten.
I got a lot of...
[mutters] What is this..."Towers of Metal."  This was it.
"Five miles beyond the mines."
Beyond the mines, far side of the mountain.
So, the mines were the closest thing to them.
Camouflaged metal towers by as- asymmetrical trees...
"I was overcome with waking dreams as of a power I had never experienced before."
"There were flames and incense and what have...
may have been mouths and may have been sex organs."
It really brings out the base level of the brain.
The lizard brain.  The base thing.
You know, it really tramps onto that, and it amplifies it.
In some way.  And it causes visions and hysteria because there's...
[frustrated growl]
I don't know.
But...
That's all we have for now.
Now remember...
In the original Outlast there was the Whistleblower DLC
which shed some more light on what was happening
And in the end the Wallrider seemed like an ethereal thing
but you know, it was- it was explained in the original Outlast
and also, you know, in Whistleblower to a greater detail.
So I would not be surprised if this had more.
Now...
All that story aside, I am gonna say about Outlast 2
the game, from a gameplay standpoint
[kissing noise]
I loved that!
It was different!
it was definitely different in certain extremes
about Outlast and the experience of that it was.
In my opinion, it had just a little bit too much
of the merry-go-round chasing and running away from people.
But it had moments...that were just gosh-darn terrifying.
I actually really liked the flipping in and out of reality aspect of it.
I think that added a lot of depth to it, and just showed
How...whatever was in that world was affecting Blake.
and how his past, and his main source of guilt
and his entire existence was just brought up.
And it was amplified, to an extreme degree.
This was a worthy successor to Outlast
but not without its flaws.
And I'm sure someone else could point out its flaws much better than I ever could
but even so...
It took the subject matter and it didn't even shy away an inkling to it.
It went as deep as you could possibly go
into the perversion, the bloodiness, the goriness
the horrific nature of this
It- it didn't skirt around religion, it didn't do ANY of that.
It hit it head-on, and I can appreciate something that takes itself seriously
to an extreme degree.
And that's what this did.
And I-I, I really really really enjoyed this.
I did, I LOVED this game.
I did, I-I...from a- from a gameplay standpoint
there were flaws and there were story flaws and there's holes, obviously!
and there's unanswered questions
but from a pure experience standpoint
That was flippin' amazing!
I had a blast! [laughing]
I was frustrated at times, but I never wanted to stop going!
But either way...
I'll leave it at that.
Let me know what you guys thought of it down in the comments below
I wanna hear your opinions about this.
I want to hear your theories about the story.
I want to know what is possibly going on here
and how it could in any way relate to the original Outlast.
Because this wouldn't be Outlast 2
if there might not be some [whining] tangentially related things.
But we'll see.
We'll see what happens in the future and we'll see what gets dug up.
[outro music starts] So thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see YOU...
in the next video!
Bye-bye!
[outro music plays]